[Musique]
une 7 heures du matin sur la rive sud du
fleuve son chat et qui sépare le
guatemala du mexique
c'est sur ce bout de rivière que
commence un ballet incessant de
clandestins ils fuient la misère de
l'amérique centrale pour tenter de
rejoindre les états unis
chaque année ils sont plus d'un million
originaire du salvador du honduras ou du
nicaragua a tenté cette route de
l'impossible vers le rêve américain
sur la rive mexicaine les militaires ne
semblent pas surpris il voit passer
jusqu'à 1000 candidats à l'exil par jour
ici pas besoin de visa quelques dollars
suffisent pour que les soldats ferme les
yeux
depuis toujours les migrants monter sur
les trains de marchandises qui partait
de la ville de tapachula les en 2006
l'ouragan stan a dévasté les voies
ferrées des côtes du chiapas
les premiers trains partent désormais de
la ville d'arriaga 250 km plus au nord
comme tous les jours on la garde arriaga
est envahie par des milliers de migrants
ils prennent d'assaut ces trains en
marche direction le nord les états unis
à 4000 km au mépris du danger
chacun tente de trouver une petite place
sur les trois entre les wagons sur les
essieux
il peut y avoir jusqu'à mille
clandestins par train
face à un tel afflux de migrants
les autorités mexicaines ont renforcé
les contrôles les forces de l'ordre
n'interviennent jamais au départ du
train elle préfère attendre la sortie de
la ville
soudain des policiers armés surgissent
le train est bloqué en rase campagne
ceux qui voyagent entre les wagons ont
une chance de s'échapper mais les
clandestins agglutinés sur les toits
sont pris au piège
ce jour-là 300 personnes vont être
arrêtés ces gens n'ont parcouru que
quelques centaines de kilomètres sur le
sol mexicain
chaque année seuls 40% des migrants
atteigne la frontière des états unis
pour cela le voyage est terminé les
autorités mexicaines vont les reconduire
à la frontière du guatemala
la plupart d'entre eux retenteront
aussitôt leur chance
les trains qui monte vers le nord se
remplissent peu à peu
hier je suis tombé du train là entre les
rames
mais grâce à dieu j'ai rien eu
d'autres migrants ont eu moins de chance
au dispensaire de la ville de nombreux
blessés sont soignés après des accidents
graves
c'est le cas de rose anna salvadorienne
en convalescence depuis un mois après
avoir été amputé des deux jambes je suis
tombé du train de voyager assis sur le
toit péter hyams et je suis tombé en
voulant descendre dans un barrage de la
police était en train de descendre et
j'ai glissé je voyageais avec notre
salvadorienne et trois ans du rien ils
ne sont même pas descendus ils ont cru
que le train avait tué sur le coup